Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
Guys. This is Rob and we are back again with juggernaut. Yes.
We're back again with the juggernaut solo series written by Fabian to Caesar,
probably one of the coolest writers that Marvel has,
and we're picking up with a trial of, of juggernaut,
but this is where the juggernaut was basically summoned to court for all the
damages caused or at least a huge chunk of damage to these costs and what
they're using here as evidence for a fight between himself and Spiderman.
And they're kind of pointing out the idea that like the fight between the two of
them had caused millions of dollars with a damage, right? And they came,
Marco was not being mind controlled, but his actions, his actions were his own.
His choices were zoned. And that karma and Angela, right,
this kind of New York city born and bred guy lost his scrappy construction
company. Now the whole thing is kind of being watched by diesel.
And technically,
I guess you can record it because she's considered herself to be part of the
press, which what really makes a person part of the press. Right?
I don't know if you really have to have like press credentials per se.
I think it's just like, I've got a phone and I want to document that.
So I am part of the press now,
whether or not you're recognized that way by the rest of the press is a whole
different discussion. But one of the things that kind of comes out of this,
and this is what's cool is that you have the,
the defense attorney essentially for Kane Marco coming out and saying, yeah,
the cane marker was not the one who destroyed this. Guy's you know, this,
this guy summit, right? This guy's Wilson, the company that was Spiderman,
who did that, that was collateral damage in the conflict.
And Spiderman was the one who caused it. Now,
this is one of the interesting things that you don't really see here because
when it comes to the superheroes and the supervillains fighting each other on
the whole, all the collateral damage that gets done, right?
So buildings being torn up or being smashed and destroyed, things like that.
That's all handled by damage control incorporated, right?
It's a company with a government contract to clean up after the superheroes.
And they don't really differentiate between who did what,
it's just a matter of this was destroyed. And then that's it,
they usually use something like eye witness, evidence,
or video evidence or something along those lines to kind of figure out who
caused what damage. But in this instance, Cain,
Marco was also stuck inside that concrete for months, right?
Like for months on end.
But Spiderman is really the one that kind of brought this down.
Now let's not because find man was being,
being terrible is because that's just the nature of what happens when
superheroes fight supervillains. And so in the midst of this whole trial,
everything basically goes South.
And what you end up getting is the arrival of essentially a Sandman character,
but not the Sandman that you're used to. But before we get into that,
we actually end up jumping back to a few months ago and kind of get this
explanation of how it was that came Marco goddess powers.
And this is somewhat of an interesting concept that Marvel's rolling in here in
his journey to find a new gender,
not suit he's basically brought to North Korea. And as he gets there,
he ends up finding what is in essentially the forge of Ciroc right now the
forges center rack is this,
this concept designed to basically build things that are in the likenesses to
direct or to honor center rock. That's kind of the way this all works.
We talked about the [inaudible] the fact that said rock is one of eight demon
entities. Uh, that was,
that kind of was part of a giant competition to essentially take control of the
world and whoever it was, you know,
whoever's forces end up destroying the other forces. What come out on top,
I guess, a little more explanations needed there.
So what you have is the artisans, and this is basically eight demon entities.
Um,
each of which were arguing over who's the most powerful and the way this works
is that each one of them put an artifact on earth.
And when the artifact was picked up,
it would begin the [inaudible]. And that's what happened with Cain, Marco
. He pickled the Crimson, Jim of sitter, Rocky
became the juggernaut, but he also started the OC test
. Now that whole thing came to a head and the eighth day storyline.
But the idea is that once the first artifact was picked up,
it would drive seven other people to want to grab the other artifacts.
And they internal what split humanity into eighths.
And then they would all go to war with each other and whichever army came out on
top, that being out there,
it represents that army would prove me that I was powerful one.
So if juggernaut basically, you know,
wiped out all the other avatars of the other demon entities and then wiped out
all the other seven eights of humanity,
then it would prove that that center rack was the most powerful.
Now the eighth day event was stopped, especially because of Thor.
He had a huge hand in that,
but this is the reason why these kinds of forces are created is because they're
designed to honor these various entities.
And there's some out there like for like [inaudible] different people out there,
you know, different beings out there like that.
There's other forces out there and other artifacts out there,
we just don't really see them anymore. But when Cain Marco gets in here,
he's basically looking for a new suit and he tells the guy this and the guy's
like, well, people have come here looking for, you know,
something of Ciroc they're looking to serve as the host of Silverback.
What makes you special? And that's when Kmart reveals,
he's actually the juggernaut and the guy up above,
and you basically see that a new suit's been created out of the Crimson bands of
Ciroc.
The Crimson bands will sit a rack or historically something used by Steven
strange.
And that's one of the things to understand about Dr. Strange himself is he
doesn't really have any powers unto himself. Instead,
his powers are linked to him by other people by their lent to him by other
beings for center rock, for example, lens Dr. Strange, the Crimson bands.
Now it seems as though these Crimson bans are no longer being linked to Steven
strange because now they're being forged into a new suit of armor.
And that's what this guy does right now though.
The other problem with this is that he spent all this time building this armor
under the belief that sit or act would see what he'd done and then see him as a
new host, right? He would say like, you know,
I bless you with becoming my new avatar because of the work you've put in to
make the soup. But as we know her ex kind of a jerk and that never happened,
it seemed like Ciroc was just waiting for Kiana Marco to return.
And so the two of them essentially get into a kind of scuffle, right?
But ultimately Ken Marco ends up coming out on top. And uh, in,
in his whole grip, acute fight, the,
the chains that are holding the suit up are basically destroyed.
And when that happens, the suit falls onto Kane, Marco, and bonds itself to him.
And he emerges as the new juggernaut. And that's how he got his new suit.
Now what its full capabilities are. We don't entirely know.
Usually whenever Marvel changes up the suit of a character,
especially if somebody like juggernaut,
because his powers come from the Crimson, Jim,
it stands to reason that there'll be upgrades, right? There'll be changed.
We saw that with Donnie Caitlin's venom, for example,
when venom encountered Knoll, he was awakened to a whole new host of abilities.
You didn't realize you had before.
So that's usually what ends up happening here is that things end up shifting up,
jumping back to the current level.
Right now you end up having DSL kind of holding off this Sandman S character as
best as you possibly can.
The funny thing about this is that the voice that's emanating from Sandman,
which basically says like, give me the girl and uh, and no one will get hurt.
This all does this voice really seems to be female. And as we know,
historically, Sandman as a guy, not only that this voice is German, right?
And so it doesn't look like it's the actual Sandman.
It looks like somebody who has the powers of Sandman, right?
Who took his powers or something along those lines. But then of course,
DSL kind of chimes in and says, her name is quicksand.
And so what you end up getting is of course, juggernaut jumping in.
But the funny thing about him is that much like the fights with Spider-Man,
you can't really fight Sandman in the traditional sense. You can't punch,
you know, anybody who's able to use sand in that way, because it's sad.
What all they do is create an opening where you fly right through them or
something like that. Instead you have to do it. Spider-Man historically dead,
which is used water, right? That's what you normally have to do, but came Marco.
Hasn't quite figured that out yet. And in fact,
it's not even really came Marco who figures that out instead where you have this
huge conflict and you have a diesel kind of watching all this unfold.
There's a couple of things that happen here.
The first is at diesel is referred to as a mute. Hence,
the reason why I said in the last video,
that's probably where she's going to end up being.
The second thing that's referred to here is that they basically realized that
she has a kind of energy source and her head.
And in order to basically stop her, you've got to remove her head essentially.
Now, again,
this is where things get a little murky here because we don't know if she's an
actual being issues,
just some kind of psychic entity that took on a energetic form and just
coalesced into a form of sand. And that's where we are right now.
We don't really know how all that works.
So what we do now is that they end up basically suffering this kind of energy
source in the head from the rest of the body. And when, when came,
Mark was able to pull that off when he does that kind of using this great big,
huge piece of metal, like a sword when he cuts it off. And basically the heads,
the girl, ah, which just kind of screwed up.
That's when this energy source is extracted and what is extracted,
there's this kind of realization. They,
they sort of go through and start analyzing it and they realize this has a
somewhat unique energy signature.
And at this energy center that it has come from only one particular location.
And when the question is,
where's this location coming from that it basically comes from absolution
solutions right now.
Anybody who knows anything about absolution solutions knows who it is that runs
this whole program, that their director of research is Artem Zola, right?
Like the old school villain. Now, before you guys are kind of like
[inaudible] in more recent years,
especially during recomenders run of captain America was actually amazing.
Like he literally had his own pocket dimension,
but he had sort of cultivated and creative and captain America was actually
stuck in there for time on the Mazola.
The funny thing about him is he's a highly capable scientist.
He's just one of these guys that largely gets ignored by Marvel,
which you wouldn't think would be the case,
especially in the aftermath of captain America, the winter soldier. Um,
I guess you really haven't seen a lot from Arnhem Zola since then,
but he's quite, quite literally one of the most dangerous minds and all of,
of Marvel comics, right? So I'm kind of curious to see where they go with this,
right? I'm kind of curious see what's happening.
But the big takeaway is that Arnhem Zola is experimenting on superhuman
prisoners.
So who knows what kind of forces we're going to see the juggernaut face off
against, which is really what I'm the most excited for with that being said,
guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys are the sub button
to become part of the Rob cork. You guys enjoy this video,
make sure you drop a light and that will cut you off.
Please.